- This all started when Dua Lipa got sued
for posting a photo of herself.
Earlier this year, British
singer Dua Lipa was sued
after allegedly posting a paparazzi photo
of herself on Instagram.
The agency which owns the picture
alleged that the Instagram
post violated their copyright
in the image.
The singer's fans were
understandably confused.
Why couldn't she post a
mundane image of herself
standing in line at an airport?
Well, according to Integral Images,
which owns the copyright,
Lipa's Instagram feed
acts as a marketing tool for her music.
The agency alleges that the photographs
intentionally infringed
on Integral's copyright
and undercut its ability
to profit from the photos.
After all, Dua Lipa didn't
pay to post that photo.
The lawsuit seeks these statutory damages
for an intentional copyright violation
that amounts to $150,000.
The agency is also asking
for an order stopping Lipa
from further acts of infringement.
Now, Dua Lipa was not
the only famous person
sued for posting a picture of herself.
Splash News sued Jennifer Lopez
for posting a Splash photo of her
holding hands with Alex Rodriguez in 2017.
A photographer sued Jessica Simpson
after she posted a photo of herself
leaving the Bowery Hotel in New York.
The photographer said that he
had only licensed the photo
for limited use to the "Daily Mail,"
but Simpson and her social
media managers tweeted it out
without licensing it.
Splash News and Picture Agency
sued Liam Hemsworth in 2018,
claiming he posted its
photos of him on Instagram
without the company's permission.
Paparazzo Robert Barbera
sued Ariana Grande
after she posted two of
his photos on her Instagram
in August of 2018.
And photographer Christopher
Pasatieri sued 50 Cent
after 50 posted photographs
taken by Pasatieri
during a 2014 reunion concert with G-Unit.
So do paparazzi
photographers have the right
to stalk famous people, profit
from selling their images,
then turn around and sue the famous person
for posting photographs of themselves?
(dramatic music)
Hey, Legal Eagles,
it's time to think like a copyright lawyer
because some of this is
not exactly intuitive.
Now, we've talked about copyright
many times on this channel.
Copyright is a legal device
that gives the creator of a work of art
the right to control
how their work is used.
When we use the word creator or author,
that could mean writers,
musicians, photographers,
architects, software developers,
or even people who design
boats for a living.
All of them are considered authors
under the American copyright law,
and the things that they
produce are works of art.
The protection for works of art
comes from the Constitution.
Article I, Section 8, Clause
8 gives Congress the power
to, quote, "promote the progress
of science and useful arts,
by securing for limited times
to authors and inventors
the exclusive right to
their respective writings
and discoveries."
Scientific pursuits like machines
or useful items are
generally given patents,
but artistic creations like novels
and photographs are
covered by copyright law.
And because copyright is
provided for in the Constitution,
it's exclusively bound by federal law.
And under 17 USC 106, if you
have a copyright in something,
you have the exclusive right
to do a number of things,
including make copies of that work of art,
make adaptations and derivatives,
distribute the work,
publicly perform a play
or perform it in front of others,
display your work in public,
digitally transmit sound recordings,
and in some circumstances, the
right to receive attribution
and prevent a destruction of a work.
And these are the rights
that photographers have
when it comes to their photographs.
According to the US Copyright Office,
the owner of a work is
generally the person
who takes the photo.
Generally, the only
time this isn't the case
is when there is a work-for-hire contract
or you have an
employee/employer situation.
And generally, you don't own the copyright
just because you are
the subject of a photo.
This could even be the case
when a person hires a
photographer to take photos
like a wedding photographer.
It depends on what's in the contract.
But if that contract is silent,
then the photographer owns the copyright
to those photos of the wedding
unless the photographer agreed in writing
to transfer or license the
copyrights to that someone else,
presumably the bride and groom.
And the damages for a single
instance of infringement
can be quite steep.
Under the Copyright Act, a
copyright owner is entitled
to an award of actual
damages and disgorgement
of all the infringer's profits
attributable to infringement.
And in the alternative, the
plaintiff can elect an award
of statutory damages for
an amount up to $150,000
for each infringement.
And that takes us to the
paparazzi versus celebrities.
In the internet age,
it's dramatically changed what's at stake
for paparazzi photographers.
In the old days, they
could take photographs
and sell them to the highest bidder,
and this was usually a
magazine or a newspaper.
Now, with the internet and social media,
there's a whole new
market for digital images.
This is a blessing and a curse.
Photographers can get their work seen
all over the world almost instantly,
but it also undercuts the
market for exclusive images
and made it much easier to infringe.
Also, since everyone has
a camera in their pocket,
there's no longer exclusivity
when it comes to
photographs of celebrities.
And meanwhile, celebrities themselves
are now content creators.
They make a lot of money by
posting images of themselves
on social media accounts.
And the top influencer accounts,
like Cristiano Ronaldo,
can get up to a million dollars per post.
And as you can see, The
Rock, Ariana Grande,
several sisters Kardashian,
and several family members Jenner
are also believed to earn
hundreds of thousands
of dollars per post.
Photographers and their
agencies claim it isn't fair
for celebrities to distribute
images of themselves
without paying for a license
for the person who took that photograph.
This is the dynamic that has
created the current environment
where celeb photographers are suing
the same people they photograph.
Now, there are lots of these cases,
but let's talk about one of the biggest,
Xposure versus Kardashian.
The UK photo agency licensed
pictures of Kardashian
leaving a Miami restaurant
to the "Daily Mail."
But when Kardashian used
those very same images
on her Instagram feed
without their permission,
it was available to all 67 million people
who follow Khloe Kardashian.
Xposure sued Kardashian for
copyright infringement in 2017
seeking damages of more
than $175,000 for the post.
Not that it would have been a defense,
but the Instagram post
didn't even credit Xposure.
And to add insult to injury,
Kardashian or her team altered the image
to remove the copyright
management information,
the watermark that showed Xposure
as the copyright owner of the image.
The copyright management
information, or CMI,
refers to the watermark indicating
where the image is from.
You might've seen things like Via Getty,
which does not mean it was taken
by a person named Via Getty.
It means that Getty owns the rights
to that particular image.
Now, we don't know what
the final terms were
in this particular case,
Kardashian and Xposure
settled the case out of court
and Kardashian deleted the post.
Kardashian apparently acknowledged
that she had indeed committed
copyright infringement
with her Instagram posts.
She tweeted, quote, "Yes!
I have to license some
of the images first.
A paparazzi sued me in the past
for reposting images of myself.
So now it just takes me a little longer
because I have to go
and license the images
so they don't get my," money bag emoji.
"Makes no sense."
Yeah, the law doesn't make sense to Khloe.
She, after all, is not the
Kardashian that became a lawyer.
And in fairness, other celebrities agree.
They contend that they are
being stalked every day
by people who want to make
money from their image
and likeness.
And to be fair, paparazzi photogs
sometimes use special lenses
to take photos of people
inside their homes.
Famous people like Princess Diana
had been literally hounded to death
by overzealous photographers.
But then on the other hand,
there are people like Lisa Rinna,
who just says to hell
with it and intentionally
and repeatedly posts images
that she hasn't licensed
and blatantly violating the Copyright Act.
Rinna has now been sued
for over a million dollars
for posting eight photographs
that she didn't license.
Rinna said that if the
photographer had demanded
a lower amount, a nominal
fee, she would have paid.
Rinna and her lawyers claimed
that the copyright law
was never intended to allow photographers
to profit from images of
celebrities and, quote,
"then turn around and sue
those same celebrities
for posting their own
images on social media."
Well, I hate to be that
guy, but actually, Lisa,
this is exactly what the
Copyright Act was designed to do.
The act gives creators
the right to sue anyone
who infringes on their work,
even if that person
happens to be the subject
of the photograph.
But not every celebrity has struck out
making arguments to the contrary.
Now, in 2018, Gigi Hadid
was sued by a photographer
who took a photograph of her
leaving her apartment building.
Hadid even struck a pose for him.
The photographer worked for
the agency Xclusive-Lee.
Hadid posted the image to her Instagram
without permission or payment.
The agency filed an infringement lawsuit
seeking statutory damages.
The law seemed to be
clear cut in this case.
Hadid posted an image of
herself that she didn't own.
This should be a slam dunk
for the agency, right?
Well, not exactly because Hadid's lawyer
got the case dismissed on a technicality.
The agency failed to
register the photographs
before filing the lawsuit.
Now, you don't have to
file with the Copyright Act
to get a copyright in something,
but filing your copyright
with the Copyright Office
gives you a bunch of benefits,
and the Supreme Court has now ruled
that actual registration of a copyright
is a prerequisite to
filing a copyright action,
which resolved a long running split
in the US circuit courts.
The New York District Court
held that the Supreme Court's decision
foreclosed the paparazzi agency's
copyright infringement
claim against Hadid.
However, this lawsuit
turned out to be notable
for other reasons because Hadid
raised some novel theories
that other celebrities
are now trying to develop
to defend themselves
against paparazzi lawsuits.
Hadid's first theory was
that she co-authored the work
since she posed and smiled.
Under this theory, she's entitled
to ownership of the image,
quote, "because she posed for the camera
and thus contributed many of the elements
that the copyright law seeks to protect."
Now, this is a stretch,
but it's not entirely without legal basis.
A joint work is a work prepared
by two or more individuals
with the intention that
their separate contributions
be merged into a single work.
Co-authors own the work's
copyright jointly and equally
unless the authors make
an agreement otherwise.
Each joint author has
the right to exercise
any and all of the
exclusive rights inherent
in the joint work.
Now the primary problem with this argument
is that for a work to be a
product of two or more creators,
there must be a shared intent.
The photographer certainly
didn't agree with Hadid
that this was a collaboration.
The picture was unplanned
and happened when Hadid
spontaneously left the apartment.
But really, the whole
point of paparazzi photos
is that they're taken without
the celebrity's permission,
and that was argued in
this particular case,
so it's hard to argue the
mutually exclusive arguments
that this was both unplanned and unwanted,
but also it was a collaboration
where everyone intended
for their efforts to become a joint work.
Hadid also argued that
her use of the photographs
should be considered a fair use,
which we've talked a lot
about on this channel.
This is definitely not your
standard fair use argument.
And Hadid argued that when
she reposted the images,
she did it with a different
purpose than the agency.
Her use was personal,
whereas the agency wanted
to exploit her popularity
for commercial purposes.
She also argued that, without
her contribution to the image,
it wouldn't really exist.
Now, the court didn't
address this argument
because the case was decided
on procedural grounds,
but Hadid sort of misses the mark
when she makes this argument.
The purpose of her use
really wasn't that different
from the paparazzi's use.
It was to exploit her
popularity in a candid photo.
She wasn't, for example,
criticizing the composition of the photo
or using the photo for
some educational purpose.
This is why people license photos
that are taken by other people.
She was effectively using the photo
for exactly the same reason
the paparazzi took the photo
in the first place.
So while Hadid made some novel arguments,
they probably wouldn't hold
water and she's probably
not gonna change copyright laws overnight.
Now what about the right of publicity?
Some celebrities have
tried to sue paparazzi
on the theory that the photographers
who profit off of someone's images
are actually violating the
celebrities right of publicity.
Wide receiver Odell Beckham,
Jr. sued Splash News
after paparazzi took
photos of an injured OBJ
outside his home in New Jersey.
The photographer sold
the image to Splash News
and Picture Agency.
Beckham posted the image to Instagram
and Splash News sued him.
Beckham filed a counterclaim,
arguing that this was
an attempt to extort him
in violation of his right to publicity.
After all, you have a right to benefit
from your own name and likeness,
otherwise, everyone could
simply use photographs of you
in a commercial context,
so there's gotta be a
line somewhere, right?
And Beckham argued in
the complaint, quote,
"Splash's licensing of photographs
of an injured Beckham not
only exploit's Beckham's image
for personal financial gain,
but is also patently gruesome."
And while this generally
relies on state law,
the right to publicity
generally protects a person
from having their likeness
used for advertising
or other commercial purposes
without their permission.
Of course, this runs straight
into the First Amendment
because you have a
right to make the speech
that you want to make.
And of course, in the case
of Odell Beckham Jr's injury,
that's certainly a newsworthy event,
which makes it receive even
more First Amendment protection.
So generally, the right of publicity
means that a photographer has
the right to take photographs
of famous people and sell or
license those photographs,
but they can't sell products
with someone's image on them.
So if you to happen to
get a great photograph
of Odell Beckham, Jr., you
could license that photograph
to a newspaper or magazine or sell it,
but you could not, however, sell T-shirts
or mugs bearing the face
of Odell Beckham, Jr.
Only he can do that or someone
that has his permission.
Now, the OBJ case settled
before the court addressed his arguments,
but generally, they were
probably going to lose
since the right of a
photographer to take the picture
of a newsworthy person is
pretty well established.
Now, if you're being
hounded by the paparazzi,
you'll probably need to stay
home to avoid their cameras.
But luckily, HelloFresh,
today's sponsor, will deliver
whether the paparazzi are there or not.
And with the new year,
HelloFresh is a great way
to eat healthily and deliciously.
In fact, HelloFresh has a whole variety
of calorie-smart, carb-smart, pescatarian,
and veggie options.
Now, I'm a do-it-yourself person
and I have to say I was
initially pretty skeptical
about HelloFresh.
I'm a pretty good cook,
so I didn't think I
really needed the help,
but I actually loved it.
Even for inexperienced cook,
HelloFresh delivers new
ingredients and recipes
that I'd never try on my own.
HelloFresh generally keeps
everyone's favorite meals
and then rotates new ones all the time.
And recently, I've enjoyed
crispy Parmesan chicken,
white cheddar wonder burgers,
and pork sausage bell pepper pasta.
Now, I don't know about you,
but I probably never would
have attempted those on my own.
And it's not just meals.
HelloFresh's marketplace
features of variety of add-ons
for breakfast, dessert,
and seasonal snacks
like energy bars and cookie dough.
And it saves time too.
I usually increase the size
of my HelloFresh serving
so I can enjoy the leftovers for lunches.
And of course, everything was
delivered straight to my door
so I didn't have to do any shopping.
The produce actually gets to you faster
than a grocery store, so it arrives
at peak freshness and flavor.
And it's also super easy to save time.
HelloFresh cuts out meal planning and prep
so the recipes only take
20 to 30 minutes to cook,
literally less time than
it would take to cook
than it would to do the shopping itself.
And it's also incredibly sustainable.
Since the ingredients are pre-portioned,
there's less prep and less wasted food.
The packaging is almost entirely made
from recyclable and
already recycled content.
And HelloFresh's carbon
footprint is actually 25% lower
than that for meals that are made
from store-bought groceries.
So if you'd like to try HelloFresh,
and I recommend that you at least try it,
you can go to HelloFresh.com
and use the code LEGALEAGLE16
for up to 16 free meals
and three surprise gifts.
So again, for up to 16 free
meals and three surprise gifts,
go to HelloFresh.com and
use the code LEGALEAGLE16
or click on the link that is below
or the one that's onscreen right now
and use the code LEGALEAGLE16.
Plus, clicking on those links
really helps out this channel.
And while you're at it,
click on this playlist over here
with my other Real Law Reviews
or I'll see you in court.